I was in a show which was the most
popular show ever in former Yugoslavia
imagined we had over two and a half
million audience live being a popular
like that you cannot even walk on the
street my name is Jasmine Geller and I'm
an actor I came as a refugee in 1993 to
escape the war over there I love my
profession I like to make people happy
when I came to Canada I realized I don't
have a tools to be an actor so I didn't
speak English you have to survive
somehow after work I was working so many
different kind of job when I was
salesperson like knocking the heart of
the world trying to sell films I was
recognized as an actor by people from
former Yugoslavia but I didn't want to
speak my language because I was so
ashamed for them to see me in that kind
of position being somebody and dropping
really to become nobody I learn English
by listening other people and start
auditioning I found agent and small part
but small part I did you know I start
working my profession again
basically being a art with an accent I
always played the worst character in
college but we meant good and very good
person
in 2016 I was nominated for Canadian
Screen Award as a Best Lead Actor in the
feature film I was like thinking of a
money go back 20 years ago being nobody
and now being nominated with her it's
it's really nice feelings
you